This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a new movie out called Pinball, the man who saved the game. It's a fun and extremely meta biopic telling the story of Roger Sharp, who, with one perfect shot, helped legalize Pinball in New York. If I pulled back just enough and the ball should go right down the center. That's saving up. That's right, pinball was banned in many states up until the 1970s. We told that story and interviewed the real Roger about 400 episodes or so ago. So if you
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。最近出了一部新电影，叫《弹珠游戏：拯救游戏的人》。这是一部非常有趣且极具元叙事色彩的传记片，讲述了罗杰·夏普的故事，他凭借完美的一击，帮助弹珠游戏在纽约实现了合法化。“如果我向后拉的力度刚好，球就会直接滚进中心。”这就是拯救游戏。没错，在20世纪70年代之前，弹珠游戏在许多州都是被禁止的。我们大约在400集之前讲述过那个故事，并采访了真正的罗杰。所以如果你
haven't gone that far back in the catalog, we wanted to give you this free replay. After that we got a new segment with Keith Ellen, a tournament champion who made the move into designing pinball machines. But first let's go all the way back to episode number 135 for amusement only. Item 4 is actions on special orders of the day that typically proceeds with the 135 for amusement only. Item four is actions on special orders of the day that typically proceeds with the Council member announcements. What you're hearing is an Oakland, California city council meeting that took place in July of 2014.
还没有回听过那么早期的节目，我们想为你提供这次免费重播。在那之后，我们有一个关于基思·埃林的全新片段，他是一位锦标赛冠军，后来转型设计弹珠机。但首先，让我们回到第135集《仅供娱乐》。第4项是关于当日特别命令的行动，通常会先进行第135集《仅供娱乐》。第4项是关于当日特别命令的行动，通常会先进行议员公告。你现在听到的是2014年7月在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市举行的一次市议会会议。
Announcements? There's a whole bunch of different issues on the agenda, everything from allegations of funds being misused. We know that there was a lot of manipulation of funds, okay? And there's been a big ripoff with those funds to announcements of neighborhood parties. Basketball, pick up game, fuel games, face painting, zoom in dancing.
公告？议程上有各种各样的问题，从资金被滥用的指控，到社区聚会的公告，应有尽有。“我们知道资金存在大量操纵，对吧？这些资金被严重挪用了。”篮球、接球比赛、燃料游戏、面部彩绘、变焦跳舞。
And producer Mickey Kapper sat to the entire meeting like a good reporter does. To hear them say this. Move the item out of the present. Move the item, Madam President. Move by Vice Mayor Reed. Seconded by Miss McElhaney. And by consensus, we'll adopt the items in the consent calendar. So they never actually say it directly.
制片人米奇·卡珀像一位优秀的记者一样参加了整个会议。听他们这样说：“将该项目移出当前议程。移出该项目，议长女士。由副市长里德动议。麦克尔哈尼女士附议。经协商一致，我们通过同意议程中的项目。”所以他们实际上从未直接说出来。
But by adopting the items in the consent calendar, what happened there is that the city of Oakland finally legalized for the first time since the 1930s pinball machines. I'm Michael Shee, I'm the founder and executive director of the Pacific Pinball Museum. The Pacific Pinball Museum, which is a collection of really cool, mostly older machines that you can still play, is in Oakland's neighboring city, Alameda. Until recently, coin-operated pinball machines were also illegal in Alameda.
但通过通过同意议程中的项目，奥克兰市自20世纪30年代以来首次将弹珠机合法化了。我是迈克尔·希，我是太平洋弹珠博物馆的创始人和执行董事。太平洋弹珠博物馆收藏了许多非常酷、大多是较旧的机器，你仍然可以玩，它位于奥克兰的邻市阿拉米达。直到最近，投币式弹珠机在阿拉米达也是非法的。
And it's the reason that we started out as a admission-based establishment and everything was on free plate. Most of the museum's pinball machines look a lot like the ones you've seen before in your local bar, but there are a few really old ones that look completely different. And pinball's design history can help explain why it was illegal for so long and why after
这就是我们最初作为一家基于门票的机构，并且所有机器都免费游玩的原因。博物馆里的大多数弹珠机看起来和你当地酒吧里见过的差不多，但也有一些非常古老的机器，看起来完全不同。弹珠游戏的设计历史可以解释为什么它被禁止了那么久，以及为什么在
nearly 80 years of being a slightly sketchy leather jacket wearing Nurdwell, pinball can now go legit and claim its place with Pac-Man as good clean family fun. Pinball evolved out of a game that was also played in a tilted cabinet, but was a bit more like billiards. You chewed the ball onto the field with a pool stick. In the 1860s, the pool queue turned into a spring-loaded plunger that you'd pull and release to launch the ball. They were simple wooden boards with glass tops, no electricity, no flashy art or colors,
近80年被视为略显可疑、穿着皮夹克的“书呆子”游戏后，弹珠游戏现在可以正名，并与《吃豆人》一起跻身于健康、纯净的家庭娱乐行列。弹珠游戏是从一种同样在倾斜柜中进行的游戏演变而来的，但它更像台球。你用球杆把球推到场地上。在19世纪60年代，台球杆变成了弹簧驱动的柱塞，你拉动并释放它来发射球。它们是带有玻璃顶的简单木板，没有电力，没有华丽的艺术或色彩，
and the game was made small to fit on top of a counter at a bar or drugstore. The mechanics of the game were simpler too. He basically did one action, pull the plunger. The ball would shoot up the right side of the board and onto the play field, where there were little pockets that would catch the ball, and then they were usually stamped with the point value. And there were pins, which looked like tiny nails that obstructed your way into the pockets. That's where pinball came from, was the nails of the pins that were driven into the board.
而且游戏被做得小巧，可以放在酒吧或药店的柜台上。游戏的机制也更简单。你基本上只做一个动作：拉动柱塞。球会射向木板的右侧并进入游戏区，那里有捕捉球的小口袋，通常上面会印有分值。还有一些看起来像小钉子的销钉，阻碍你进入口袋。这就是“弹珠游戏”（Pinball）的由来，即钉入木板的销钉。
And the first games weren't coin-operated. Bars would buy one. And they would rent it out to people that were wanted to play it and gamble with it. It was kind of like running out the card table. with it. It was kind of like running out the card table. By the 1930s, Pimmel games were coin-operated. And you'd find these little countertop games all over the place, in bars and drugstores. You know, you'd buy an egg cream to drink and some horrible tasting elixir at the local
最初的游戏不是投币式的。酒吧会买一台，然后租给那些想玩并以此赌博的人。这有点像出租牌桌。到20世纪30年代，弹珠游戏变成了投币式的。你会发现这些小型的台面游戏随处可见，在酒吧和药店里。你知道，你在当地药店买一杯蛋奶饮品和一些味道糟糕的药剂，然后用找零去玩几把弹珠游戏。也许你会赢一包口香糖或雪茄。你玩得很开心。然后它演变成了纯粹的赌博。
drugstore, and you'd use your change to play some pinball. And maybe you'd win a pack of gum or cigar. And you'd have fun doing it. Then it moved to just straight up gambling. Where instead of being awarded a prize, you were given cash. And it's around this point that pinball became electric. Lights and buzzards started showing up along with other stuff like bumpers that you could bounce off of to get more points. Points that needed to be tallyed up on a scoreboard which led to what is now referred to as the back glass. That's the part of the pinball machine that faces you as you play. And the art on the back glass became one of the most iconic things about
奖品不再是实物，而是现金。就在这时，弹珠游戏开始通电了。灯光和蜂鸣器开始出现，还有其他东西，比如可以反弹以获得更多分数的保险杠。分数需要在记分牌上统计，这导致了现在所说的“背板玻璃”。那是你玩游戏时面对的那部分弹珠机。背板玻璃上的艺术成为了弹珠机最具标志性的特征之一。
the pinball machine. On the newer games, a lot of the art is licensed from movies, like the 1991 hit blockbuster The Atoms family. But if you go into the pinball museum in Alameda, almost all the old games from the 30s and 40s were done by one of two artists. George Mullenton and Roy Parker. The art was meant to appeal to men and boys, so a lot of it features pictures of pretty ladies. The back glass of a game called Marble Queen depicts a group of women in swimsuits and high heels gathered around in a circle
在较新的游戏中，很多艺术设计是电影授权的，比如1991年的热门大片《亚当斯一家》。但如果你走进阿拉米达的弹珠博物馆，几乎所有30年代和40年代的旧游戏都是由两位艺术家之一创作的：乔治·穆伦顿和罗伊·帕克。这些艺术旨在吸引男性和男孩，所以很多都以漂亮女士的图片为特色。一款名为《大理石女王》的游戏的背板玻璃描绘了一群穿着泳衣和高跟鞋的女性围成一圈
playing marbles. They're surrounded by a big tall fence almost like they're in a clubhouse. I used to do the guys that are picking through the fence and it's pretty funny. The ultimate fantasy of a boy from the 1930s was women in their bathing suits playing marbles. The lights and buzzers and women in bathing suits just made you want to put more and more money into the machines.
玩弹珠。她们被围在一道高高的栅栏里，就像在俱乐部里一样。我过去常做那些透过栅栏偷看的家伙，这很有趣。20世纪30年代男孩的终极幻想就是穿着泳衣玩弹珠的女性。灯光、蜂鸣器和穿着泳衣的女性只会让你想往机器里投入越来越多的钱。
Sometimes people were just playing a win-a-free game. Other times, there was a bigger payout, but it all added up. These things made a ton of money. I can't emphasize enough of that because the mafia got involved. It was all cash. With so much money disappearing into pinball machines,
有时人们只是为了赢取免费游戏而玩。其他时候，会有更大的回报，但这一切都加起来了。这些东西赚了很多钱。我怎么强调都不为过，因为黑手党介入了。这全是现金。随着这么多钱消失在弹珠机里，
the authorities started cracking down. It really got heated in the 40s. More and more laws were being enacted to make pinball gambling harder. Manufacturers would try to get around this by labeling the machines. It says right here, for amusement only, no prizes, no wagering.
当局开始进行打击。这种情况在40年代变得非常激烈。越来越多的法律被制定出来，使弹珠赌博变得更加困难。制造商试图通过给机器贴标签来规避这一点。上面写着：“仅供娱乐，无奖品，无赌博。”
I mean, they put that right on the machine and everybody knew that, well, that's exactly what it was for. By the end of the 1940s, pinball was banned in most major cities, including Chicago and Los Angeles. But perhaps nowhere was the pinball crackdown so extreme as in New York City, where in 1942, Mayor LaGuardia ordered the NYPD to round up all of the machines. Then, in a press event, the mayor personally shattered some of the machines with a sledgehammer and had them dumped into the Hudson River.
我的意思是，他们直接把那行字贴在机器上，每个人都知道，嗯，这正是它的用途。到20世纪40年代末，弹珠游戏在大多数主要城市被禁止，包括芝加哥和洛杉矶。但也许没有哪个地方的弹珠游戏打击力度像纽约市那样极端，1942年，拉瓜迪亚市长下令纽约警察局收缴所有机器。然后，在一次新闻发布会上，市长亲自用大锤砸碎了一些机器，并将它们倾倒进哈德逊河。
LaGuardia later reported that 2,000 new police Billy clubs would be made from the wooden legs of old pinball machines. Perfect for knocking the heads of pinball plane hooligans. Mayor LaGuardia did not succeed in ridding the world of pinball entirely, though. It was still legal in some cities, and even in New York, it didn't totally disappear. It just moved into CD underground establishments. Meanwhile, the game designers were still developing new features, the most important of which were the flippers that first appeared in 1947 that allowed you to swap the ball around the playfield by
拉瓜迪亚后来报告说，将用旧弹珠机的木腿制作2000根新的警察警棍。非常适合敲打弹珠游戏流氓的头。不过，拉瓜迪亚市长并没有成功地将弹珠游戏从世界上彻底清除。它在一些城市仍然合法，即使在纽约，它也没有完全消失。它只是转移到了阴暗的地下场所。与此同时，游戏设计师仍在开发新功能，其中最重要的是1947年首次出现的挡板，它允许你通过
pressing two buttons on either side of the machine. In other words, the flippers gave you some control over the outcome of the game. Remember, when pinball machines were first banned, the games were considered a game of chance. You'd basically put your quarter in, pull back the plunder, and hope for the best. When the flipper was added to the pinball machine, it should have changed the game's legal status. It wasn't a game of chance anymore. You could finally control the ball. If only they could find some way to prove it.
按下机器两侧的两个按钮来在游戏区内拨动球。换句话说，挡板让你对游戏结果有了一定的控制权。记住，当弹珠机最初被禁止时，它们被认为是机会游戏。你基本上投入硬币，拉回柱塞，然后祈祷好运。当挡板被添加到弹珠机上时，它本应改变游戏的法律地位。它不再是机会游戏了。你终于可以控制球了。如果他们能找到某种方法来证明这一点就好了。
Ladies and gentlemen, I give you Roger Sharp. I guess at one point I was considered to be, if not the best player in the world, one of the best players in the world. Nearly 40 years after the introduction of the flipper, in April of 1976, Roger Sharp was called upon to prove that pinball was a game of skill before a meeting of the New York City Council. On the day of the hearing, tensions were high. It was packed. A lot of camera crews. The New York State Coin Operated Amusement Game Association
女士们，先生们，我向你们介绍罗杰·夏普。我想在某个时候，我被认为是世界上最好的玩家之一，如果不是最好的话。在挡板引入近40年后，1976年4月，罗杰·夏普被要求在纽约市议会的一次会议前证明弹珠游戏是一种技巧游戏。听证会当天，气氛紧张。现场挤满了人。有很多摄像组。纽约州投币式游乐游戏协会
had arranged for the hearing and they'd hauled two pinball machines into the meeting room. One that Sharp was to play and another that would serve as a backup in case the first one suddenly died. And I started going over to the game that had been designated. The council had been pretty antagonistic to Sharp. They thought he would cheat. And right before he was supposed to play, a council member stopped him.
安排了这次听证会，他们把两台弹珠机拖进了会议室。一台是夏普要玩的，另一台作为备用，以防第一台突然坏掉。我开始走向那台指定的机器。市议会对夏普相当敌对。他们认为他会作弊。就在他准备玩之前，一位议员拦住了他。
He said, no, not that game. That game over there. I think that the head of the city council thought that that game was somehow rigged. Let's go with the game that's been turned off that nobody's paid any attention to that's over there in the corner. The council session took a 20 minute recess
他说：“不，不是那台。是那台。”我想市议会主席认为那台机器被动了手脚。我们选那台关着的、没人注意的、在角落里的那台吧。市议会休会了20分钟，
so that the camera crews could change the lighting from the original machine to the new machine. And then Roger Sharp steps up and starts playing. Back then I was able to really show off. So it was very nice to be able to call my shots and just do whatever I wanted to do, making backhands and shots for right to left, the left to right.
以便摄像组将灯光从原来的机器调整到新机器上。然后罗杰·夏普走上前开始玩。那时候我真的能炫耀一下。所以能够指哪打哪，随心所欲地做反手击球，从右到左，从左到右，感觉非常好。
And then for the grand finale, Sharp wanted to prove that even the first shot, the one that involves just pulling back the plunger and letting go, that even that shot can be perfected with skill. So he turns to the council members and says, If I do this right, it's going to land right down the center. Pull back the plunger, it went up and ball was straight down the center.
然后是压轴戏，夏普想证明即使是第一击，那个只需拉回柱塞并松开的动作，即使是那一击也可以通过技巧来完善。所以他转向议员们说：“如果我做得对，它会直接落在中心。”拉回柱塞，球向上弹起，直接落入中心。
And the guy was at the seat council, kind of threw up his head. He said, and I was right, I was right to keep on playing. I was having fun. City council voted 6-0 to pass the legislation. Sharpe has said in the past that he got lucky with this shot. It's not fun. City Council voted 6-0 to pass the legislation. Sharpe has said in the past that he got lucky with this shot, but now he says that he was being modest, that his blunge was not luck. To do what I did, that was skill.
市议会的那个人有点吃惊。他说：“我是对的，我继续玩是对的。我玩得很开心。”市议会以6比0投票通过了该法案。夏普过去曾说他那一击是运气好。这不是玩笑。市议会以6比0投票通过了该法案。夏普过去曾说他那一击是运气好，但现在他说他当时太谦虚了，他的那一击不是运气。能做到我所做的那样，那是技巧。
To have done it the way that I did it was pure naivete. Within a year, pinball was legal again in most places across the country, but not in Oakland and Alameda, where as we heard in the beginning of the show, pinball just became legal in 2014. Even with the rise of video games, the pinball industry continued to experience waves of success until the 1990s, but over time, people lost interest. The last big corporation to manufacture pinball machines lost millions of dollars on its pinball division and decided to shut down in favor of a more profitable operation, making slot machines for casinos.
能以我那种方式做到，纯粹是天真。一年之内，弹珠游戏在全国大部分地区再次合法化，但在奥克兰和阿拉米达除外，正如我们在节目开头听到的那样，弹珠游戏直到2014年才合法。即使随着电子游戏的兴起，弹珠游戏行业在20世纪90年代之前继续经历着成功浪潮，但随着时间的推移，人们失去了兴趣。最后一家制造弹珠机的大公司在弹珠部门损失了数百万美元，并决定关闭该部门，转而从事利润更高的业务——为赌场制造老虎机。
After decades of fighting to prove that pinball could be a game of skill, it turned out that the most lucrative bet for game makers was on games of chance gambling machines. You know, Bally's casino, they used to be in the pinball business and they took their name from their first hit pinball machine manufactured in 1932 called Ballyhoo. Welcome to the 21st century. In 1999, pinball tried to make a comeback with a game that integrated a video screen on the back glass with a mechanical play field. Welcome to Pinball 2000. Welcome to the new image in Pinball. Welcome to the 21st century.
在为证明弹珠游戏是技巧游戏而奋斗了几十年后，事实证明，游戏制造商最赚钱的赌注是机会游戏——赌博机。你知道，巴利赌场，他们过去是做弹珠生意的，他们的名字取自他们1932年制造的第一台热门弹珠机，叫“Ballyhoo”。欢迎来到21世纪。1999年，弹珠游戏试图通过一款在背板玻璃上集成视频屏幕和机械游戏区的游戏卷土重来。欢迎来到《弹珠游戏2000》。欢迎来到弹珠游戏的新形象。欢迎来到21世纪。
That was a promo video for Pinball 2000, despite the reverb and the menacing ticking clock, and the mountains of hyperbole heaped upon the promotion of the game, it never really got on. Which is probably because if Pinball still has any appeal, it's actually the vintage, analog nostalgia feelings it brings up in people. We like it because it's not the future. It's the past. Back at the Pacific Pinball Museum,
那是《弹珠游戏2000》的宣传视频，尽管有混响、威胁性的滴答声，以及堆砌在游戏宣传上的夸张辞藻，但它从未真正流行起来。这可能是因为如果弹珠游戏还有什么吸引力的话，那实际上是它带给人们的复古、模拟的怀旧感。我们喜欢它，因为它不是未来。它是过去。回到太平洋弹珠博物馆，
Mike Shees thinks Pinball is making a bit of a comeback. And it's because people are longing to get away from screens and from games that they play at home alone. So with Pinball, you can kind of gather around and watch your friends suck. And that's the other thing that's really cool is that anybody can suck at pinball. I mean, it's a great equalizer. You don't have to be smart. You don't have to be physically an athlete.
迈克·希认为弹珠游戏正在复苏。这是因为人们渴望远离屏幕和独自在家玩的游戏。所以有了弹珠游戏，你可以聚在一起看你的朋友出丑。这是另一件非常酷的事情，任何人都可以玩得很烂。我的意思是，这是一个伟大的平衡器。你不必聪明。你不必是身体上的运动员。
I think what he means is that anybody can suck and anybody can be great. It's a nerds game, a rebels game, an underdog's game. After the break, I talked to Martín Gonzales about the many layers of modern pinball. We are back with Martín Gonz is hey, Martin. Hey, what's up, Roman? Hey, not much. I heard you talking about pinball last week on that deer hankin' John the way played. That's right. Does that mean you've been taking advantage of it? Now that's legal in Oakland. I have. I mean, I, I'm not a very good pinball player, but when I see it in a place like the stay gold barbecue in Oakland I'll throw some quarters into a pinball machine for sure
我想他的意思是任何人都可以玩得很烂，任何人也可以玩得很棒。这是一个书呆子的游戏，一个叛逆者的游戏，一个失败者的游戏。休息之后，我和马丁·冈萨雷斯谈谈现代弹珠游戏的许多层面。我们回来了，马丁·冈萨雷斯，嘿，马丁。嘿，怎么了，罗曼？嘿，没什么。我上周听到你在那个《亲爱的汉肯·约翰》节目里谈论弹珠游戏。没错。那意味着你一直在利用它吗？既然在奥克兰合法了。我有。我的意思是，我不是一个非常好的弹珠玩家，但当我在奥克兰的“Stay Gold”烧烤店看到它时，我肯定会往弹珠机里投几个硬币。
I find pinball to be just it's intoxicating in a way like even if you're bad at it Watching it is very very fun. So but how long have you been playing? Well, I used to actually cut class and music school to go play at the music plays across the street. I was like, Baroque theory 101 or attack from Mars, like easy choice. Okay. But I started playing a lot more when I was living in Portland, Oregon, which is just like a real pinball
我发现弹珠游戏令人陶醉，即使你玩得很烂，看着它也非常非常有趣。那么，你玩了多久了？嗯，我过去常逃课去音乐学校对面的游戏厅玩。就像是“巴洛克理论101”还是“火星攻击”，很容易选择。好吧。但我住在俄勒冈州波特兰市时开始玩得更多了，那里简直就是弹珠游戏的麦加。
mecca. So just to put it in context, New York, where I live now, has a population close to 8.5 million people and there's about 200 pinball tables But the greater Portland metro area has 2.2 million people and over a thousand tables. Oh, okay That's very precise. How do you know all these pinball statistics? Well, there's this great crowdsourced website called pinball map And it shows you what machines are where and people couldn't leave comments on like, what's broken when they swap a machine out. Right, kind of like a pinball, 3-1-1.
为了说明背景，我现在住的纽约人口接近850万，大约有200张弹珠台。但波特兰大都会区有220万人，却有一千多张台子。哦，好吧。这非常精确。你怎么知道所有这些弹珠统计数据？嗯，有一个很棒的众包网站叫“弹珠地图”（Pinball Map）。它会显示什么机器在哪里，人们可以在上面留言，比如什么坏了，什么时候换了机器。对，有点像弹珠界的3-1-1服务。
Yeah, exactly. And it also helps like, you know, whenever I travel, I check to see if like, there's any rare games I want to play and you're where I'm going. Nice. I was a little different. Okay, so when the story originally came out, we left off on pinball, just starting to make a comeback.
是的，完全正确。而且它也有帮助，你知道，每当我旅行时，我都会查看我要去的地方是否有我想玩的稀有游戏。不错。我有点不同。好吧，所以当这个故事最初出来时，我们停在了弹珠游戏刚刚开始复苏的地方。
And it kind of feels to me like, I see a lot of new machines. Like, where are things at? Pinball's gotten much more broadly popular in that time. And now we're in kind of like a pinball Renaissance. Like, it's more popular than ever. But we talked in the story about how, by the end of the 90s, manufacturers were getting
对我来说，感觉就像我看到了很多新机器。那么现在情况如何？弹珠游戏在那段时间变得更加广泛流行。现在我们正处于一种弹珠游戏的复兴时期。它比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。但我们在故事中谈到，到90年代末，制造商们正在
out of the pinball business like the big flop of Williams' pinball 2000, 1000. So around that time, Sega sold off their pinball division, data east, to Gary Stern, who'd been running it since 1986. And Stern's been just cranking out these really high quality games for 24 years now. And for a long time, they were like the only game in town, but now there's a bunch of boutique manufacturers producing new machines and licensed reissues of some of those really great 90s era Williams tables. And in 2020, a lot of enthusiasts bought home machines because they had extra disposable income and had no hard to go play.
退出弹珠业务，比如威廉姆斯《弹珠游戏2000》的惨败。所以大约在那个时候，世嘉把他们的弹珠部门“Data East”卖给了加里·斯特恩，他从1986年就开始经营它了。斯特恩24年来一直在生产这些高质量的游戏。很长一段时间里，他们是城里唯一的玩家，但现在有一群精品制造商在生产新机器，并重新发行了一些90年代威廉姆斯时代那些非常棒的台子。2020年，许多爱好者购买了家用机器，因为他们有额外的可支配收入，而且没地方去玩。
Yeah, sure. I know one of those people. Oh, yeah. Yeah, can I come over and play? And these modern games are also just like a lot deeper and more advanced and interesting than earlier games were. So in what way are they more interesting? Because I agree.
是的，当然。我认识其中一个人。哦，是吗？我可以过去玩吗？这些现代游戏也比早期的游戏更深入、更先进、更有趣。那么它们在哪些方面更有趣呢？因为我同意。
Like when I see a new modern pinball machine, it is, first of all, really beautiful and just gorgeous how the ball rolls and the ramps and everything, but they kind of stress me out because I'm kind of just like, keep the ball alive, flipper guy, and I don't know how to do any of the missions. And if I get into multi- multiple, it is by pure chance.
就像当我看到一台新的现代弹珠机时，首先，它真的很漂亮，球滚动的样子、坡道等等都很华丽，但它们让我感到压力，因为我基本上只是在想：“保持球活着，挡板小伙子”，我不知道怎么完成任何任务。如果我进入多球模式，那纯粹是偶然。
You know, yeah, multi ball is like its own crazy thing. Like really good players will do this thing where they hold a couple balls in one flipper and like just shoot with the other one, which is I'm still trying to figure that one out. So yeah, the actual skills are the same across games, but the thing you're talking about like all the objectives and shots, they're different for every table, and it can just be really daunting to keep all this in your head. Most of them have this little cheat sheet in the lower left corner,
你知道，是的，多球模式有它自己疯狂的地方。真正的高手会做这种事，他们用一个挡板接住几个球，然后用另一个挡板射击，我还在试图弄清楚那个。所以是的，实际技巧在不同游戏中是一样的，但你说的那些目标和射击，每个台子都不同，把所有这些记在脑子里确实很让人望而生畏。大多数机器在左下角都有这个小作弊表，
and there also tends to be visual cues like lit arrows to communicate what the next move should be. And that can be the difference between a game that's frustrating and possible to figure out, whereas one that you can just like shoot and have a nice time, even if you don't have a bunch of stuff memorized. Right. I mean, this is where the real hardcore game design comes in, because you're really trying to balance a player like me
而且往往会有视觉提示，比如亮起的箭头来传达下一步应该做什么。这可能就是让游戏变得令人沮丧还是可以弄明白的区别，而有些游戏你只需要射击就能玩得很开心，即使你没有记住一堆东西。对。我的意思是，这就是真正硬核游戏设计发挥作用的地方，因为你真的在试图平衡像我这样的玩家
who can just walk up and play it versus someone who tries to master it and doesn't get frustrated. Right. And there's even in the pinball movie Roger Sharp's character gets a line in about that. That is a game of champ. That is a game of skill. Actually, it's better than that. That is a game of choices.
可以走过去直接玩，和那些试图掌握它而不感到沮丧的人。对。甚至在弹珠电影里，罗杰·夏普的角色也有一句台词。“那是机会游戏。那是技巧游戏。实际上，它比那更好。那是选择游戏。”
Everything that is on that play field was put there for a reason. I've spent time with the people that have created this game. They're not criminals. They should be celebrated. And doing this episode was a great excuse for me to spend some time myself with one of the most celebrated non-criminal designers working today. Hi, I'm Keith Owlin. I've been competing in pinball since 1993. I've won the most majors in tournament history, currently 11. And now I am a game designer at Stern Pinball. I've won the most majors in tournament history currently 11. And now I am a game designer at Stern pinball.
游戏区上的每一件东西都是有原因的。我花时间和创造这个游戏的人在一起。他们不是罪犯。他们应该受到赞扬。做这一集对我来说是一个很好的借口，让我自己花点时间与当今最受赞扬的非罪犯设计师之一在一起。嗨，我是基思·奥林。我从1993年开始参加弹珠比赛。我赢得了锦标赛历史上最多的重大赛事，目前是11次。现在我是斯特恩弹珠公司的游戏设计师。
I've designed iron maiden Jurassic Park Avengers, Godzilla and the bond 60th anniversary edition. Now Keith's not one for bragging. So I'm going to do it for him that he's pretty widely considered one of if not the best players of all time. The world's best pinball player. He has been named the goat for many reasons. Best player in the world, best designer. Oh, is that too early? But even though his first commercial design
我设计了《铁娘子》、《侏罗纪公园》、《复仇者联盟》、《哥斯拉》和《邦德60周年纪念版》。现在基思不是一个喜欢吹嘘的人。所以我来替他吹嘘，他被广泛认为是史上最好的玩家之一，如果不是最好的话。世界上最好的弹珠玩家。他因许多原因被称为GOAT（史上最佳）。世界上最好的玩家，最好的设计师。哦，这太早了吗？但即使他的第一个商业设计
was only released five years ago, he was practically born for it. My dad would always have like scrap wood nails, you know, whatever, I'd be born, I'd take a scrap of wood, hammer a bunch of nails and put some rubber bands on it. And hey, look, I made a pinball machine and you know, use my fingers or blocks of wood as flippers.
五年前才发布，他简直就是为此而生的。我爸爸总是会有一些废木头、钉子之类的东西，我会拿一块废木头，钉上一堆钉子，套上橡皮筋。嘿，看，我做了一台弹珠机，你知道，用我的手指或木块作为挡板。
That's so endearing. Yeah, I absolutely love that mental image. But so I asked them about the transition from being just a player to also designing. One thing I've noticed that I didn't really pay attention to when I was a player is that there are generally two types of pinball players, the ones that they just want fun, kinetic action. They want to score as many points as they can. And then there's the other set of players who are really into the story. It's like, I want to, you know, see what every mode, every video.
这太可爱了。是的，我绝对喜欢那个心理画面。但所以我问他关于从玩家转型为设计师的过程。我注意到的一件事是，当我还是玩家时我没有真正注意到的，那就是通常有两种类型的弹珠玩家，一种是只想要有趣、动感的动作。他们想尽可能多地得分。然后是另一类玩家，他们真的很喜欢故事。就像，“我想看看每一个模式，每一个视频。”
And when he said that, I was like, Oh, that second one is like my true nature. I like to just like shoot around and see what's there. I frankly, never used to really care too much about what score I got. I was just like trying to have a good time. So when you actually game in a tournament, you're going to see players just make the same four shots over and over. It's just a good point. Rinse and repeat.
当他说那句话时，我想，哦，第二种就像我的本性。我喜欢只是四处射击，看看有什么。坦率地说，我过去从来不在乎我得了多少分。我只是想玩得开心。所以当你真的在锦标赛中玩游戏时，你会看到玩家一遍又一遍地做同样的四次射击。这只是一个好点。不断重复。
Some players enjoy doing that. And you got to kind of give the little carrot for them. It's like, yeah, if you skillfully do this thing over and over, you can get a lot of points. But the average player is just like, yeah, I don't want to do that. I want to see what else this game has. So yeah, when I want to design a game get a lot of points. We don't even know how to open up a new level or story mode. We're just trying to keep that ball on the table. Yeah, exactly. It has to have enough there to be fun for casual players too. And even Keith gets bored with just shooting for points. When I first started designing, I always thought, oh, it would be so awesome to have a game where you're just completely in control
有些玩家喜欢这样做。你得给他们一点胡萝卜。就像，“是的，如果你熟练地一遍又一遍地做这件事，你可以得到很多分。”但普通玩家只是觉得，“是的，我不想那样做。我想看看这个游戏还有什么。”所以是的，当我设计游戏时，我们甚至不知道如何开启一个新的关卡或故事模式。我们只是试图把球留在桌面上。是的，完全正确。它必须有足够的内容，让休闲玩家也觉得有趣。甚至基思也会对只为了得分而射击感到厌烦。当我刚开始设计时，我总是想，哦，如果能有一款游戏让你完全掌控
all the time, but then I, yeah, and my later designs, I'm realizing that the outer control parts are what makes it fun and challenging. Basically, like, okay, Roman, you always feel out of control and like you're gonna die at any moment. And Keith's trying to give that experience
一直掌控，那该多棒，但后来，在我的后期设计中，我意识到失控的部分才是让它变得有趣和具有挑战性的原因。基本上，就像，“好吧，罗曼，你总是感到失控，感觉随时都会死。”而基思正试图提供那种体验
to like even the people at the top of their game. The terror of losing is actually what makes it fun. Right, right. They should feel more like me. I like this. This is very good. And that's what makes it more fun than a video game. Like no matter how you design it
给那些处于游戏顶端的人。失去的恐惧实际上才是让它变得有趣的原因。对，对。他们应该感觉更像我。我喜欢这个。这非常好。这就是它比电子游戏更有趣的原因。无论你怎么设计它
or how well you can play it, there's always that physics element that makes it a little bit of random and unpredictable. Yeah, I mean, I think that's one of the reasons why pinball is so fun to sort of line up along the sides and watch someone play because the ball is bouncing around in this physical space and there's always like a little bit of a chance that there's a little bit of
或者你玩得有多好，总有那种物理元素，让它有一点随机和不可预测。是的，我的意思是，我认为这就是为什么弹珠游戏在侧面排队观看别人玩很有趣的原因之一，因为球在这个物理空间里弹跳，总是有那么一点点机会，有一点点
wobble or like, you know, the ball like hits the glass and then smacks down really hard. It's always fun. And the ball is moving so fast. Sometimes even just a couple milliseconds of reaction time, we'll make it go, hit a different ramp or go in a different direction. But some shots are a little easier to predict and hit repetitively than others that might send it corigning around.
晃动，或者你知道，球撞到玻璃然后重重地砸下来。这总是很有趣。而且球移动得太快了。有时甚至只需几毫秒的反应时间，就会让它去撞击不同的坡道或朝不同的方向走。但有些射击比其他可能导致它四处乱撞的射击更容易预测和重复命中。
But it's not any different than any other player of any sport with a ball in it. It's all about risk reward and making the player feel like, okay, I know what I know if I shoot this shot, the ball's going to be dangerous, a good chance I'm going to lose it. But this is the chance I'm taking to get this multi ball or the jackpot, you know, whatever big payoff is. I mean, is it ever a problem that he is so good that, you know, he would design a shot inside of a pinball machine that he could make, but really no one else could make. I mean, I've had that same experience sometimes playing his games where I'm like, all right,
但这与任何其他有球运动的玩家没有什么不同。这全是关于风险回报，让玩家觉得，“好吧，我知道如果我射出这一球，球会很危险，很有可能我会输掉它。但这是我为了获得多球模式或大奖，或者任何大回报而冒的险。”我的意思是，他太厉害了，以至于他会在弹珠机里设计一个他能做到但实际上没人能做到的射击，这会是个问题吗？我的意思是，我在玩他的游戏时有时也有同样的经历，我想，“好吧，
this must be easy for him, but, you know, so I asked him about it. Sometimes, I get that a lot on Jurassic Park, but here's my philosophy. If you make a game with all these e-shots, you're never gonna have that wow moment. Oh, I did it. You want at least one or two hard shots in every game that people are initially frustrated, but then when they make it, they're like, yeah, that's awesome.
这对他来说一定很容易，但是，你知道，所以我问了他。有时，我在《侏罗纪公园》上经常遇到这种情况，但这是我的哲学。如果你制作一款全是简单射击的游戏，你永远不会有那种‘哇’的时刻。‘哦，我做到了。’你希望每款游戏中至少有一两个高难度射击，人们最初会感到沮丧，但当他们成功时，他们会说，‘是的，那太棒了。’”
And another cool thing about modern games is that they're actually connected to the internet. Like they have Wi-Fi built into them and they get their software tweaked over time. And something I love about Keith is he'll purposely put in these risky shots that make you lose control. And then he goes back in and makes sure that the incentives are good enough for people to go for them. One of my favorite things to do is like, one of my game releases, I'll watch the top players
现代游戏的另一个酷之处在于它们实际上连接到互联网。它们内置了Wi-Fi，软件会随着时间的推移进行调整。我喜欢基思的一点是，他会故意加入这些让你失去控制的冒险射击。然后他回去确保激励措施足够好，让人们去尝试。我最喜欢做的事情之一是，在我的游戏发布时，我会看顶级玩家
play because a lot of them stream and I'll see them either avoiding shots entirely or just hitting the same shots over and over. And then so I'll go to Rick Nagle, my programmer and I was like, yeah, we need to do something about this. How about we try this or we'll put our next ball here. Okay. Now you can aim for it. Yeah.
玩，因为他们很多人都在直播，我会看到他们要么完全避开射击，要么一遍又一遍地击中同样的射击。然后我就去找我的程序员里克·内格尔，我说：“是的，我们需要对此做点什么。我们试试这个，或者我们把下一个球放在这里。好吧。现在你可以瞄准它了。”是的。
Okay. You know, I start to see people start to aim for it. He did this a lot on Godzilla, which is currently number one of all time on this pinball forums, a long-running list of like the best games ever. And you know, so I watched one of these videos he's talking about and sure enough, this amazing player couldn't resist the reward. So he took a risk to try and get the extra ball. The sensible thing to do now probably is to trap up.
好吧。你知道，我开始看到人们开始瞄准它了。他在《哥斯拉》中做了很多这样的事，该游戏目前在弹珠论坛上排名史上第一，这是一个关于史上最佳游戏的长期列表。你知道，所以我看了他谈到的其中一个视频，果然，这个了不起的玩家无法抗拒奖励。所以他冒了个险试图获得额外的球。“现在明智的做法可能是接住球。”
I'm not gonna, I'm gonna play it. Oh, don't die. I really want this extra ball. And he lost control. Ah! Wow, I mean that's really like the heart of an iterative design process. I just didn't think that was possible in pinball because it's this big massive machine. You know, like he can't go in there and like, you know, move a ramp a little bit to make sure it's better. But he can, you know, tweak the code and then make it so that, you know,
“我不打算，我要玩它。哦，别死。我真的很想要这个额外的球。”然后他失去了控制。“啊！哇，我的意思是那真的是迭代设计过程的核心。我只是没想到这在弹珠游戏中是可能的，因为它是一个巨大的机器。你知道，他不能进去，你知道，移动一下坡道以确保它更好。但他可以，你知道，调整代码，然后让它，你知道，
if it's worth the risk, he can like rebalance it. You know, he'll also make certain objectives easier if he sees players struggling to reach them. Oh, I love this. This makes me really want to play when he has games. Well, it's like I've got pinball map open here. Looks like there's a Jurassic Park three blocks away from the Oakland office. If you want to see if you can make one of these in possible shots, I will never make it.
如果值得冒险，他可以重新平衡它。你知道，如果他看到玩家难以达到目标，他也会让某些目标变得更容易。哦，我喜欢这个。这让我真的很想玩他的游戏。好吧，就像我这里打开了弹珠地图。看起来离奥克兰办公室三个街区外有一台《侏罗纪公园》。如果你想看看你是否能完成这些不可能的射击，我永远做不到。
But you know, at least I can admire its craft. I mean, have you ever gotten the urge to play in a tournament yourself and use some of this knowledge, well, I've just always been a little scared too. Like, there's this kind of like very macho, bro. You like slam on the machine around and like, oh, I got the high score kind of thing that like kind of intimidated me.
但你知道，至少我可以欣赏它的工艺。我的意思是，你有没有冲动自己去参加锦标赛并利用这些知识？嗯，我一直有点害怕。就像，有一种非常大男子主义、兄弟会的感觉。你像猛撞机器，然后，“哦，我得了高分”，那种让我有点害怕的东西。
But, you know, my friend Michelle, who she works at WFMU, shot out WFMU. Oh, the great WFMU. Yeah, they put a pinball team together. So, she talked to me into it. She was like, you know, it's okay to just go and suck. You don't have to win to have a good time. So, I thought like, all right, you know, I'm talking to Keith.
但是，你知道，我的朋友米歇尔，她在WFMU工作，向WFMU致敬。哦，伟大的WFMU。是的，他们组建了一个弹珠队。所以，她劝我参加。她说：“你知道，去玩得很烂也没关系。你不必赢也能玩得开心。”所以，我想，好吧，你知道，我正在和基思交谈。
I'm doing this episode. I just got to get over my fears and go do one. So, last week, I went to Jack Barr and Brooklyn for their regular Thursday night knockout tournament. The rules are you plan the same machine with one or two other people, the lowest score gets a strike and three strikes and you're out.
我正在做这一集。我必须克服我的恐惧去参加一次。所以，上周，我去了布鲁克林的“Jack Bar”参加他们定期的周四晚淘汰赛。规则是你和另外一两个人玩同一台机器，最低分得一个罢工，三个罢工你就出局了。
Okay, so how'd you do? So I got off to a really rough start on Cactus Canyon. I was just like super nervous. First of all, I'm up against Hunter. He got five million. I got one million, not looking good so far. I ended up losing that game, and suddenly I just didn't really feel nervous anymore.
好吧，那你表现如何？所以我一开始在《仙人掌峡谷》上表现非常糟糕。我当时超级紧张。首先，我的对手是亨特。他得了500万。我得了100万，目前看起来不太好。我最终输掉了那场比赛，突然间我不再感到紧张了。
Like, oh, like, losing's not so bad. And then I ended up having a nice surprise in my second round. I had a creature from the Black Lagoon second, which is actually one of my better games. Even though I didn't do too well by my usual centers, I did better than the other two people, so I'm alive a little longer. But in round three, I got my ass kicked in Spider-Man,
就像，哦，输掉比赛也没那么糟糕。然后我在第二轮有一个小惊喜。我第二场玩的是《黑湖妖潭》，这实际上是我比较擅长的游戏之一。虽然我按我的通常标准表现得不是很好，但我比另外两个人做得好，所以我多活了一会儿。但在第三轮，我在《蜘蛛侠》上被踢了屁股，
apparently I'm playing against one of the best here, and I got absolutely shredded It wasn't even close. And then in round four, I actually captured the moment that I got knocked out of the tournament. I am playing Star Wars against Hunter who I played on my first game. Typically not one of my best games. I watched a video last night to try and find a strategy for it. But I think, yeah, he just passed me. So it's going to be my third strike. He'd watched the same video and he remembered a lot more of it. But still, that's not so bad
显然我是在和这里最好的玩家之一比赛，我被彻底粉碎了。甚至都不接近。然后在第四轮，我实际上捕捉到了我被淘汰出锦标赛的那一刻。我正在和亨特玩《星球大战》，我在第一场比赛中和他玩过。通常不是我最擅长的游戏。我昨晚看了一个视频试图找到策略。但我认为，是的，他刚刚超过了我。所以这将是我的第三个罢工。他也看了同样的视频，他记得更多。但即便如此，那也没那么糟糕
for your first time. Yeah, I had so much fun and I was really high off of that one victory. So I actually went to another tournament two days later and I won three out of my first four games. So I was like feeling great. But then I got eliminated with strikes on Iron Maiden and Godzilla, which are two of Keith's games. So I'm sorry Keith, I tried my best for you. Well, I am just proud that you've used your job here as an excuse to play penball. Anytime you need me to, I'm quite happy to. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Mickey Kapper, who originally made the story back in 2014 with production assistants from Katie Mangle and Sam Greensman. Our team Gonzales produced and remixed the rerun. Original music by Swan Raill,
对于你第一次来说。是的，我玩得很开心，我真的因为那一次胜利而感到兴奋。所以我两天后又去参加了另一场锦标赛，我在前四场比赛中赢了三场。所以我感觉很好。但后来我在《铁娘子》和《哥斯拉》上被淘汰了，这是基思的两款游戏。所以我很抱歉基思，我为你尽力了。好吧，我只是为你用这里的工作作为借口去玩弹珠游戏而感到自豪。任何时候你需要我，我都非常乐意。本周的《99%隐形》由米奇·卡珀制作，他最初在2014年制作了这个故事，制作助理是凯蒂·曼格尔和萨姆·格林斯曼。我们的团队冈萨雷斯制作并混音了重播。原创音乐由斯旺·雷尔创作，
plus Kansas City stomp by Jelly Roll Mourn. Many thanks to Keith Owin for talking with us. Thanks also to Zach Sharp, Josh Rube, Michelle Colomere, and Maya Raskovich. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstead, is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Jason Dillion, Lasha Madadon, Vivian Le, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia
加上杰利·罗尔·莫恩的《堪萨斯城跺脚舞》。非常感谢基思·奥林与我们交谈。也感谢扎克·夏普、乔什·鲁布、米歇尔·科洛梅尔和玛雅·拉斯科维奇。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、杰森·迪利恩、拉莎·马达顿、薇薇安·勒、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚
Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family, still headquartered in beautiful, law abiding, uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI-O-RG. As long as you don't tweet to tell me that I should have made a pinball wizard joke. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99-PI
克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Stitcher和Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部仍然设在美丽的、守法的、上城的加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIORG。只要你不发推特告诉我我应该讲一个“弹珠巫师”的笑话。我们在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上也有账号。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。
at 99- at 99PI.org. This is an emergency broadcast. The Earth is being invaded by flies also from Stinger. Mamma mia! Save the tower of bees! Your cities will be destroyed! A TORK! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 99- 在 99PI.org。这是一次紧急广播。地球正受到来自斯廷格（Stinger）的苍蝇入侵。我的天啊！救救蜜蜂塔！你们的城市将被摧毁！一只大黄蜂！这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。